bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo en compagnie
de michaël szames us bonjour quel dans
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
cette semaine il y a eu bien sûr jacques
chirac condamné à deux ans de prison
avec sursis dans la sphère des emplois
fictifs de la mairie de paris
un ancien président de la république
rattrapé par les affaires
c'est une première historique il ya eu
cette semaine aussi les déclarations
françois hollande s'il est élu président
le candidat socialiste renégociera
l'accord européen renégociation aussi
pour les retraites des affirmations qui
lui valent les qualifications d'
irresponsable et de menteur par la
majorité
enfin on reviendra sur la foire
d'empoigné dans l'hémicycle lors des
questions au gouvernement à faire du pas
de calais contre affaire karachi la
majorité et les socialistes se sont
envoyé à la tête les affaires du moment
la nervosité monte à quatre mois de
l'élection présidentielle est avec nous
cette semaine bruno le roux bonjour
députés du parti socialiste vous est
surtout connu pour être l'un des fidèles
de françois hollande on vous a beaucoup
vu entendu pendant les primaires
socialistes vous êtes aujourd'hui l'un
des quatre porte parole de campagne du
candidat socialiste laurent fabius a dit
ces derniers jours au sein d'une réunion
du parti socialiste qu'il fallait plus
de sniper est ce que vous considérez
comme un sniper
je sais pas mais en tout cas j'ai
vocation dans cette campagne et à
relayer de la parole de françois
hollande a expliqué à aller sur les
plateaux comme ici pour pouvoir donner
ce que va être la façon dont ils
envisagent le redressement puis en même
temps dans une période où à droite on
essaye de soulever toute une série de
problèmes ou en fin de compte on ne
devrait pas avoir à le faire ils ont
déjà fort à faire à essayer d'expliquer
ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui a expliqué
comment ils ont trompé les français et
en fin de compte ou comment ils se sont
trompés et donc moi je suis là aussi
pour dire l'état du pays dira l'état
réel et répondre aux mensonges du
président de la république et de ses
ministres cissé c'est un peu ça c'est un
débat politique c'est d'exposer les
idées françois hollande va le faire qui
sait aussi que nous allions quand il y à
un certain nombre de propos qui sont
tenus comme ces derniers jours par le
président de la république ou par ses
ministres d'hier ce qui nous semble
folle ce qui nous semble vrai dire la
situation réelle du pays
est ce que vous estimez que françois
hollande on a fait un bon démarrage de
campagne jusqu'à présent mais je
considère que nous ne sommes pas encore
véritablement campagne le président de
la république n'a pas annoncé sa
candidature nous nous avons désigné
notre candidat mais françois hollande a
dit que ce serait pour le début de
l'année qu'il ferait l'annoncé de son
projet présidentiel les axes qu'il va
proposer aux français et pour autant
nous sommes en situation de déplacement
nous sommes en situation déjà de
préciser quelques idées donc oui je
pense que la procédure des primaires a
été une procédure qui a donné beaucoup
de force à notre candidat est
aujourd'hui je me rends compte que cette
force
elle n'a pas disparu bien au contraire
que les français aujourd'hui marque
qu'ils ne veulent plus de nicolas
sarkozy et marque en même temps que le
seul possible demain pour le remplacer
c'est françois hollande ne vous vous
considérez donc que vous êtes dans un
entre deux avec une baisse légère quand
même dans les saunas jouer une baisse
quand même c'est pas facile à gérer cet
entre deux si vous pensiez que
l'élection présidentielle au mois de mai
prochain
allait se jouer à 62,38 comme on nous le
disait c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
la réelle j'ai cette baisse justement
mais en travaillant en travaillant et en
allant à la rencontre des français nous
avons un avantage avec nicolas sarkozy
c'est que nous ne sommes pas obligés
de déplacer les militants socialistes
pour aller sur le terrain nous pouvons
aller à la rencontre des français et
françois hollande y va il sera encore en
début de semaine prochaine à saint
nazaire après avoir été au creusot après
avoir été dire ceux qui le souhaitent
bien politiques européens à tenir quand
même jusqu'en mai prochain
mais il est en pleine forme je veux vous
rassurer ceux qui lui résistent qu'on
peut s'user un tout petit peu dans le
discours ne s'usera pas si l'on est dans
l'espoir si l'on suscite aujourd'hui les
éléments qui vont permettre de redresser
la france si l'on parle aux français en
essayant de ne plus les tromper comme
ils l'ont été pendant cinq ans alors il
n'ya pas d'usure l'usure c'est quand les
français vous condamne au mensonge dit
que vous ne pouvez plus rien à leur dire
et donc il y a de ce point de vue là un
climat qui a mis en place nicolas
sarkozy qui est un climat dur pour la
politique
ilham entier aujourd'hui les français se
disent une nouvelle fois est ce que
quelqu'un va être capable de nous
proposer un chemin de nous dire la
vérité et c'est en cela que les quatre
mois de campagne qui viennent vont être
importants nous allons rendre l'espoir
aux français
mais bruno le roux on va passer à
l'actualité de la semaine à ce climat
dont vous parlez à cette campagne qui
n'en est pas une encore d'après vous
l'actualité du lundi c'est françois
hollande sur l'air quand même de si
j'étais président si j'étais président
mais françois hollande et bien je
renégocierait l'accord de bruxelles
j'introduirai les eurobonds et une
banque centrale européenne plus fortes
paroles relayée dans cette journée du
lundi par ses proches elisa bartholomé
trois jours après l'avoir créé nicolas
sarkozy continue de soutenir avec force
son traité intergouvernemental dans une
interview au journal le monde le
président de la république parle d'une
étape décisive vers l'intégration
européenne et d'un accord qui crée les
conditions du rebond et de la sortie de
crise
un traité qui est loin de faire
l'unanimité à gauche le ps propose un
contre-projet basée sur plus de
croissance et moins de rigueur
le candidat françois hollande a lancé
l'assaut dès ce matin cet accord n'est
pas la bonne réponse
si je suis élu président de la
république je négocierai renégocier cet
accord pour y mettre ce qu'il lui manque
aujourd'hui des propos qui remettent en
cause la crédibilité de la france selon
le premier ministre françois fillon
puis pour les socialistes le
gouvernement n'a pas de leçon à donner
la position de renault gociations est
une position extrêmement réaliste qui a
des précédents et qui peut rencontrer
des interlocuteurs et donc c'est une
position sérieuse
on ne peut pas accepter qu'elle soit
discrédité comme a voulu le faire
françois fillon encore une fois il n'a
aucune leçon à donner
ce premier ministre qui a trouvé une
situation mauvaise qu'il a aggravée à la
tête du gouvernement
et puis ensuite la démocratie c'est ça
mais les motivations du ps vis-à-vis de
ceux traités restent flous les
socialistes donnent peu d'explications
sur les conditions de renégociation
surtout les proches de françois hollande
refuse de se prononcer sur son mode de
ratification alors on a entendu à
l'instant pierre moscovici le directeur
de campagne de françois hollande parler
de françois fillon mais je propose un
d'écouter le premier ministre on débat
juste après la meilleure façon de
soutenir le triple à des pays européens
c'est de défendre l'accord du 9 décembre
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire qu'il n'était pas
responsable de la part du candidat
socialiste de prétendre qu'il allait
pouvoir à lui tout seul le remettre en
cause
chacun sait que c'est tromper les
français quand 26 pays avec des
gouvernements de gauche comme des
gouvernements de droite s'est mis
d'accord sur une des dispositions qui
permettent d'assurer la pérennisation de
l'euro on ne prétend pas qu'on va leur
mettre tout seul on va prolonger le
raisonnement de françois fillon qu'est
ce que françois hollande a donc de plus
que nicolas sarkozy qui pourrait imposer
des règles que angela merkel ne veut
absolument pas il faut partir d'abord de
la réalité à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui
si j'entends les propos du premier
ministre cet accord ce nouveau traité
cette perspective de traité devait
permettre d'envisager la sortie de crise
et ont la relier à la confiance que vont
faire les marchés dans notre continent
européen et à l'évidence quelques jours
après le premier ministre et le
président de la république ont annoncé
aux français en essayant de banalise
ce qui pour eux étaient quelque chose
d'absolument inacceptable il ya encore
quelques semaines
la perte de la note triple à des cas là
vous ai déjà perdu
je ne sais pas si c'est perdu je ne le
souhaite pas mais en même temps quand
j'entends le président de la république
là après nous avoir dit que la france
devait tout faire pour sauver parce que
c'est d'avoir des conséquences pour
notre pays et donc pour les français
dire aujourd'hui que ce ne serait pas
grave je pense que l'on est dans de
l'inconséquence total vais pas
l'impression d' instrumentaliser tout ça
à des fins partisanes comme et il n'y a
pas d' instrumentalisation
quand le président de la république nous
dit que c'est quelque chose auquel on
doit tenir comme à la prunelle de ses
yeux et qu'il nous fait crois que l'on a
fait des plans de rigueur qui ont touché
les français pour maintenir ça pour
faire cette protection
et bien moi je le dis non simplement le
président de la république n'a jamais
protégé les français
durant ces cinq années mais il n'a même
pas protégé la france alors si ce triple
a est si important pourquoi ne pas voir
voter la règle d'or d'abord la règle
d'or n'a pas été proposé elle est en ce
moment elle est un slogan ou navire mais
les ailes avant je vous retourne vous
qui être des journalistes de la chaîne
parlementaire comment se fait-il que
vous n'ayez pas interroger le premier
ministre le président de la république
sur le fait qu'il ne respectait pas
l'article 34 de la constitution
l'article 34 qui a été modifiée en 2008
c'est à dire il y a simplement quelques
années impose un objectif d' équilibre
des comptes publics
c'est déjà dans notre constitution d'une
règle d'or mais il n'y a pas besoin
ce qu'il faut c'est de la volonté quand
françois hollande dit aujourd'hui oui je
demanderai la renégociation du traité
c'est parce qu'il entend que les pays
européens ne sont pas contents de la
façon dont ce traité a aujourd'hui été
discuté et que l'austérité généralisée
tant pour les marchés que pour standard
and poor's que pour les peuples
européens
ce n'est pas une perspective il n'y a
pas de croissance que permet aujourd'hui
le traité et donc quand nous mettons sur
la table des outils les euro obligations
le rôle de la banque centrale européenne
le roc de la balle sans trac
d'investissement c'est bien pour recréer
de la confiance
aujourd'hui je suis au regret de dire
que monsieur sarkozy et madame merkel ne
crée aucune confiance et donc n'offre
aucune perspective d'avenir des hangars
qu'elle est
nicolas sarkozy écoutez je mets ma la
merkel d'abord parce qu'à l'évidence
c'est elle qui décide aujourd'hui en
europe et le président de la république
nicolas sarkozy qui suit
madame merkel mais en même temps je
l'aimais ensemble lui derrière et elle
devant revient la question initiale
breton leroux comment françois hollande
arriverait si la imposé à l'allemagne
première puissance européenne des règles
dont elle ne veut pas dont les euro
bonds dont une une banque centrale
européenne plus forte et le
décisionnaire d'abord parce que la
situation économique va s'imposer et que
l'on va bien voir que les mesures qui
sont prises aujourd'hui par mme merkel
ne permettent pas remplir les objectifs
elle installe l'austérité elles ne
permettent pas de croissance et donc il
faudra bien négocier avec des nouveaux
outils et il faudra aller négocier avec
l'allemagne et il faudra que madame
merkel se confronte aussi quelques mois
après les français au jugement des
allemands il y aura je l'espère une
alternance politique en allemagne aussi
en toutes façons de toute façon je pense
qu'il nous faudra avoir des outils
qu'ils soient des outils qui permettent
la croissance qui permette le retour de
la confiance il n'y en a aucun dans le
projet de traité et quand je dis projet
de traité c'est que vous savez bien
qu'il n'y aura pas avant l'élection
présidentielle de traité qui sera signé
par les 27 états ce n'est pas vrai on
fait aujourd'hui mais c'est impossible
il peut y avoir un accord
intergouvernemental mais le traité nazis
mais jamais signé on sait bien la
difficulté qu'il y à a signé un traité
c'est à dire que le ce qui a été fait
par nicolas sarkozy ne répond ni à
l'urgence de la situation
la situation des dettes européennes né à
la perspective de croissance que doit
aujourd'hui incarner l'europe et donc on
voit bien qu'il y a là un accord qui ne
permet aucun règlement de la situation
actuelle nous sommes d'ailleurs question
bruno le roux nicolas sarkozy lors des
différentes conférences de presse disait
on sent bien qu'on est en période
électorale et c'est pour cela que le
parti socialiste est bien joue un petit
peu avec les accords est ce que vous
n'avez pas l'impression justement qu'il
faudrait un consensus national sur cette
question on peut pas y avoir ce
gouvernement est nul et il est fier de
l'être
en plus il n'a jamais su protéger les
français il ne s'est pas protéger le
pays aujourd'hui avec l'annoncé de la
perte du triple à lequel ils
s'accrochaient et en même temps ils
diraient que c'est l'opposition qui
instrumentalisent ça non nous ce que
nous souhaitons c'est un chemin
différent un chemin de crédibilité un
chemin de volonté et un chemin qui
permettent à tous les français de se
sentir respecté le vrai problème dans
notre pays c'est que les 75 milliards de
cadeaux fiscaux
il manque aujourd'hui à l' équilibre
budgétaire il manque aujourd'hui dans la
situation où nous sommes et ça c'est le
président de la république arrive à
passer au mardi à nouveau candidat
encore pour la présidentielle
deux jours après avoir annoncé
officiellement sa candidature dominique
de villepin avait rendez vous avec les
journalistes pour une conférence de
presse aux accents gaulliens pendant
laquelle il s'est dit déterminé à aller
jusqu'au bout et côté le pourvoi que le
candidat du modem déjà répondu à cette
question indiquant qu'il se rallierait
soit à la droite soit la gauche je le
dis très clairement ici le ralliement ne
fait pas partie de mon programme
ce n'est pas mon tempérament et ce n'est
pas l'idée que je me fais d'une élection
présidentielle les français choisissent
et ce n'est pas par des combinaisons
politiciennes partisane que doit se
décider du sort d'une campagne
électorale
alors là non de dominique de villepin ce
qu'elle vous a surpris un peu comme tout
le monde nous journalistes et politiques
coûté non parce que elle est une
conséquence de l'échec de nicolas
sarkozy
là aussi si le bruit si le président de
la république l'a encore expliquons les
choses si le président de la république
avait réussi il rassemblerait son camp
s'il ne rassemble pas son camp c'est
bien parce que dans son propre camp on
juge qu'il a échoué
on juge qu'il a échoué sur sa politique
est sûr que dominique de villepin soit
réellement dans le camp de nicolas sa
moi je veux vous l'assuré 2002
vient de la droite vient de la droite il
a été premier ministre de jacques chirac
il n'a jamais eu sa carte du parti
socialiste qu'il n'a jamais défendu les
idées qui étaient les idées de la gauche
il a su défendre la france quand il le
fallait mais pas les idées de la gauche
est aujourd'hui s'il est candidat c'est
bien parce qu'il estime que nicolas
sarkozy a mis la france dans une
situation qui est une situation qu'il ne
peut pas cautionner que personne ne peut
cautionner et donc je remarque que les
multiples candidatures qui lie à
aujourd'hui et notamment à droite sont
la marque de l'échec du président c'est
un code de la route bientôt penser qu'il
ira jusqu'au bout
écoutez je ne pense pas que ce soit une
candidature de deuxième tour d'abord je
n'imagine pas que l'alternative à ces
indicateurs choisis soit dominique de
villepin pour autant ça peut être une
candidature de premier tour bien entendu
c'est à lui me voir et je crois surtout
si c'est un candidat majeur
c'est une candidature pour en finir avec
le sarkozysme
globalement le sarkozysme politique le
sarkozysme en tant que méthode de
gouvernement de la france
je crois que personne n'est très fier
aujourd'hui du président de la
république que nous avons est que avec
des mots différents
françois hollande dominique de villepin
d'autres candidats le disait trop de
monde sur la ligne de départ à votre
avis pour cette élection présidentielle
solide à tous les jours presque oui en
même temps si l'on voit la logique de
nos institutions si l'on n'est pas
candidat on a du mal à exister à
l'évidence on sait aujourd'hui que si
nicolas sarkozy n'est pas réélu
c'est parce qu'il aura été remplacé par
françois hollande françois hollande est
le seul aujourd'hui à incarner la
capacité à battre nicolas sarkozy à
gagner et à porter un projet a animé une
majorité derrière et donc je crois oui
qu'il faut faire attention à la
dispersion
mais cette dispersion elle est la
conséquence je crois de la faiblesse de
nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui aller mardi
toujours retour sur des propos de
françois hollande qui font encore
polémique cette fois sur les retraites
il a à préciser sa position sur la
question retraite à 60 ans quand on a
commencé à travailler tôt le reste sera
soumis aux négociations
la majorité évidemment hurlent à la
trahison des promesses non tenues
clémentine maligorne était prévisible
les propos de françois hollande sur les
retraites ont fait mouche cet après-midi
dans l'hémicycle
et c'est le nu
straw du travail prix monter au front
nous avons du mal à suivre la ligne du
parti socialiste pour les retraites hier
matin même en cherchant à camoufler les
choses
on l'a compris monsieur hollande a menti
il n'y aura pas le retour à la retraite
à 60 ans voilà la preuve du mensonge
le candidat socialiste la veille avait
précisé sa position
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler à 18
ans pourront partir à 60 ans à la
condition seulement qu'ils aient leurs
41 ou 42 années de cotisations pour tous
les autres il y aura négociation
on est loin du retour à la retraite à 60
ans moi j'écoute au jour le jour les
changements de cap du candidat hollande
et jeudi que ses changements de cap
incessants de semble incompatible avec
l'exercice
son été pour lui parle lui d'une
fonction présidentielle
moi j'ai vu françois hollande
juré la main sur le coeur qui si
toutefois la gauche revient au pouvoir
et la vie en 2010
elle supprimerait cette réforme je les
ai vus faire on voit qu'en fait il a
renoncé difficile de revenir en arrière
d'autant que dans le budget rectificatif
les députés ont accéléré le calendrier
de la réforme des retraites une bonne
oloron c'est ce que vous allez répondre
à cela la position de françois hollande
n'a pas changé d'un iota
il n'avait jamais promis le retour à la
retraite à 60 ans mais le parti
socialiste oui le gouvernement a mis
huit millions de personnes dans la rue
quand on fait contre sa réforme des
retraites c'est parce qu'elle était
ressenti comme injuste et nous voulons
la clarté vous avez raison de le dire
françois hollande n'a jamais dévié d'une
seule d'un seul millimètre sur votre
votre argent amateurs de la semaine il
est clair que le parti socialiste le
programme du parti socialiste
écoutez mon à leur retour à 60 ans oui
mais la position de dos qui ne nuit pas
il ya un certain nombre d'éléments et ce
débat sur les retraites a été un des
débats des primaires tranchée par plus
de 3 millions de votants et il est clair
pour françois hollande la priorité à
tous ceux qui ont été les ceux qui ont
travaillé le plus ceux qui ont commencé
jeunes doivent pouvoir partir à 60 ans
or aujourd'hui ils ne le peuvent pas ils
doivent pouvoir partir si l'on
quarante-et-une bientôt 42 annuités ça
sera rendu possible dès le lendemain de
l'élection et ensuite nous ouvrons la
négociation avec une priorité ceux qui
sont les abîmer du travail ceux qui ont
dû travailler dans leur vie sur des
emplois qui sont particulièrement
difficiles et à ceux là nous disons la
pénibilité sera prise en compte
enfin dans le calcul de la retraite a
écarté au temps du projet socialiste il
été fait jusque là mais nous refait
tissu économique est question de
stratégie politique
or notre système de retraite doit être
financé le projet du gouvernement ne
l'ait pas aux docks le projet socialiste
n'était pas viable
mais le projet socialiste il manquait
très certainement de précision celle
qu'apporte aujourd'hui françois hollande
quand nous disons la retraite à 60 ans
oui bien entendu
nous revenons à l'âge légal de départ à
60 ans puisque nous permettons aux
salariés de le faire et en même temps
nous ne souhaitons pas demain que tout
le monde sans négociations puissent
partir à 60 ans parce que moi ce que je
vois depuis plusieurs années dans ma
circonscription
ces deux retraités pauvres c'est des
retraités qui ont des décotes tellement
forte qu'elle ne leur permettent plus de
vivre normalement et que la société n'a
pas intérêt à avoir des retraités qui
s'appauvrissent de plus en plus il ya
quand même une proposition sur laquelle
françois hollande a quand même changé
c'est important les français pouvaient
pour lui partir à 60 ans avec décote
maintenant leur dit non ses plus petites
on nous met concerne donnons nous
mettons ça dans la négociation françois
dans les négociations alors on verra
il faut respecter les partenaires
sociaux ce qu'ils demandent c'est une
négociation
nous leur offrons et nous disons vous
devrez faire des choix avec nous il y
avait tout un courageux à l'époque eric
woerth qui avait négocié sion non la
négociation discuter avec les syndicats
aujourd'hui ils n'appellent pas
négociations ce qui a été fait par le
gouvernement actuel où on les a mis dans
quelques pièces pour avoir quelques
discussions et en même temps on
l'annoncé des choses à l'assemblée
nationale qui n'avait rien
voir avec ce qui a été dit qu'ils
étaient injustes des débats ce que nous
voulons c'est la justice dans la réforme
des retraites que ceux qui ont eu des
métiers pénibles puissent partir avant
ceux qui ont eu des métiers moins
pénible maintenant des mesures concrètes
précises sur cette pénibilité n'est pas
un peu commode de renvoyer effectivement
tout à négocier la pénibilité c'est une
négociation étant mais en même temps ça
doit être une marque de fabrique demain
de la nouvelle majorité du nouveau
président est né de l'arrêt sur échouent
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait avant 8h
saura prendre ses responsabilités mais
je n'imagine pas demain que mettant tous
les partenaires sociaux autour de la
table nous n'arrivions pas à des mesures
de justice car c'est cela que nous
souhaitons mettre en place au coeur de
la réforme de la retraite le sentiment
pour les français qu'elle soit juste
qu'elle soit financée qu'on ne soit pas
obligé de revenir tous les deux ou trois
ans pour faire des efforts et demander
des efforts supplémentaires et en même
temps qu'il y ait de la justice au coeur
de la réforme avant peut-être de
stratégie politique est ce que le
positionnement de françois hollande
dérive un petit peu vers centre droit
peut-être proche de françois bayrou car
il faut pas oublier qu'il y à un premier
tour il ya aussi ferait sûrement le
plein des voix socialistes mais aussi
peut-être penser aux voix centristes non
ce qui intéresse consolante c'est le
rapport qu'il a avec les français il n'y
a pas une petite musique derrière qui la
danse musique ça doit être de rendre
l'espoir de redresser le pays et de
faire en sorte qu'il soit juste que la
justice soit au coeur des décisions
on imagine bien et françois hollande le
dit demain qui ne sera pas facile
l'élection présidentielle ne va pas
régler la situation de notre pays
le président prochain aura fort à faire
mais il faudra le faire avec des
critères qu'ils soient très différents
des critères qui permettent la
crédibilité
le redressement du pays et en même temps
que les français se disent là la
décision qu'on propose enfin elle est
juste alors on va parler d'un autre
sujet le made in france tous les
candidats ont ce mot à la bouche
françois bayrou marine le pen françois
hollande on va en parler à l'instant on
ne coûte à ce sujet le chef de l'état il
était en déplacement ce mardi en haute
savoie
vous allez l'entendre il défend le
concept mais avec une légère variante
tout le monde tant lâcheté français
moi je préfère parler de produire en
france
au fond je préfére mail sans citer non
qu'on achète une voiture d'une marque
étrangères produites en france le taux
qu'une voiture d'une marque française
produite à l'étranger ramener en france
la question absolument stratégique
absolument essentiel c'est de garder la
france comme une terre de production
bono lors ou alors il vaut mieux
produire français ou acheter français
si je devais remplir le bulletin
puisqu'on est en fin d'année là nicolas
sarkozy jamais déjà en bas un menteur
copieurs ça fait pas un bon bulletin ça
parce que après avoir menti aux français
sur des mesures qui ont dégradé la
compétitivité des entreprises qui n'ont
pas lutter contre les délocalisations
aujourd'hui on vient reprendre ce qui a
été le thème du déplacement et des trois
déplacements dernier de françois
hollande sur la compétitivité des
entreprises et commander un rapport il
ya deux ans à yves jégo qui lui a été
remis et commander un travail que ça
quand on est au gouvernement on fait
autre chose que de commander les
rapports on essaye de prendre des
mesures qui soient dès lundi la question
est claire ashley français produire
français est bien entendu qu'il faut
restaurer la compétitivité et il faut
faire en sorte d'avoir de la valeur
ajoutée qu'ils soient produites dans
notre pays car c'est bien ça qui est au
coeur quand on dit produire français
consommer français
c'est un slogan nous ce que nous voulons
demain c'est que l'on introduise en
france sur notre territoire par des
process industriels par des politiques
volontaristes de la valeur ajoutée que
l'on crée de la valeur ajoutée dans
notre pays parce que la valeur ajoutée
c'est de l'emploi et la valeur ajoutée
c'est de la croissance de demain sont
des discours on sait bien qu'on a on a
on a une compétition avec notamment les
pays émergents qui est énorme sur et que
quand on produit français on est
obligatoirement plus cher donc tout
simplement mais il à vous poser la nième
réalité est là vous poser la bonne
question à laquelle françois hollande
répond par la réforme fiscale
aujourd'hui nous avons une fiscalité sur
les entreprises qui devient
particulièrement qui est devenu
particulièrement injuste qui empêche
l'investissement dans notre pays nous le
reverrons dans le cadre de la réforme
fiscale et je pense qu'il faudra poser
l'interdît des délocalisations
la question n'est pas d'intérêt la
question et faire en sorte de redonner
des éléments de compétitivité mon
entreprise d'arrêter de faire payer sur
elle portait sur elle de nouvelles taxes
comme ils l'ont aujourd'hui pour les pm
d'avoir des vraies filières où l'état
aide à la mise en place de nouveaux
process industriel à l'innovation et
cela je remarque que la politique
industrielle a été la grande absente
alors qu'en période de crise est une
dimension sur lesquels on doit investir
ça a été la grande absente de la
politique de nicolas sarkozy dont
réforme fiscale discussions sur la façon
dont on finance la protection sociale
dans notre pays le coût du travail
ça c'est des éléments qui doivent de
moins de 13 ans ont des bases saines
question à savoir est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est une bonne chose de tout mettre
sur le dos de nicolas sarkozy et de ne
pas reconnaître que le contexte est tel
que c'était extrêmement difficile monde
sait qu'il y à la crise et tout le monde
sait en même temps qu'il y a à côté de
la tamise la politique de nicolas
sarkozy
les français savent bien qu'avant la
crise il y a eu le paquet fiscal les
cadeaux qui ont été faits aux plus
riches dans notre pays les cadeaux
fiscaux
est-ce qu'ils ont été remis en cause
ensuite quand il ya eu la crise n'ont
aucun tous les autres pays autour de
nous ont remis en cause leur politique
nicolas sarkozy à dinan j'avais raison
alors qu'ils avaient tort et cd
ressentie par les français comme une
véritable injustice et donc oui je le
pense nicolas sarkozy dans une période
de crise n'a pas su protéger les
français n'a pas su être à leur écoute
et on le voit bien aujourd'hui avec la
dégradation qui est attendu qu'il
annonce lui-même de notre pays qu'il n'a
même pas su protéger la france est un
président de la république en faillite
allez on va passer au mercredi jour de
règlement de compte à l'assemblée
il y a comme cela des jours de climat
électrique entre les députés et en ce
mercredi ce sont les affaires qui vont
occuper les séances de questions au
gouvernement
pas de calais contre affaires karachi et
pour être honnête ce jour là c'est l'ump
qui tire en premier compte rendu de
thomas souliers
la séance est ouverte cet après midi à
l'assemblée il essoufflé comme un air de
campagne présidentielle droite contre
gauche afer contrat afer l'hémicycle a
pris des allures de ring de boxe
si la parole est à sébastien huyghe
premier rand
le député ump du nord enfilé gants sa
cible le ps après laffaire guérini dans
les bouches du rhône après la sphère de
la fédération ps de l'hérault
c'est au tour de la région nord pas de
calais d'être entachée par les affaires
du parti socialiste et de se retrouver
sous les feux de l'actualité judiciaire
le ton monte et l'opposition réplique
deuxième ronde
deux députés socialistes passent à
l'offensive sur l' affaire karachi
ces insinuations monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres
scandaleuse car s'il y en a qui ont des
comptes à rendre sur les rapports qu'ils
entretiennent avec injustice et vous
mesdames messieurs les membres du
gouvernement c'est vous qui refusez de
lever l'intégralité du secret défense
sur karachi qui refusait que la vérité
éclate alors que chaque semaine un
proche du pouvoir et mises en garde à
vue l' affaire karachi concerne nicolas
sarkozy
ma question est la suivante que savait
et quel était le rôle de nicolas sarkozy
ministre du budget
nous attendons vos explications
troisième et dernier rendent le
spécialiste du dossier karachi bernard
cazeneuve veut prendre la parole le
micro reste est un nazi dans l'état
gwendal rouillard
mais je cazeneuve j'ai c'est monsieur
gwendal rouillard qui doit conduire les
chers collègues je suis fort préoccupé
par la dégradation de la qualité de nos
débats regret le règlement mais lui agit
en partisans ump et non en président de
la représentation nationale à cause de
la tension poser la question dont
l'hémicycle le débat devient inaudible
dix minutes avant l'heure réglementaire
bernard accoyer siffle la fin du match
la séance est levée on se dit toujours
son et spectacles un petit peu désolant
est ce que c'est pas parce que c'est bon
pour les partis traditionnels de tels
spectacles afer contrat afer
non c'est pas bon mais quand on veut
essayer d' instrumentaliser les choses
et quand on n'aime pas en même temps ne
permet pas à la justice de faire son
travail
c'est ce qui arrive c'est que le débat
arrive dans l'enceinte politique et moi
je le regrette profondément ce vote
alizée ou vous répondait aussi du tac au
tac finalement réduction nous répondons
est ce que c'est bon finalement est ce
que vous devriez pas faire un peu la
tête basse et des romains s'est passé on
en reste aux noms quand il y à une
affaire quand il ya une affaire où il y
a plusieurs morts français dont on voit
bien kharafi la paire karachi dont on
voit aujourd'hui qu'un certain nombre de
documents ne veulent pas être rendus
publics par le gouvernement et dont on
peut présumer que le président de la
république nicolas sarkozy a des liens
avec cette affaire était en situation de
responsabilité
alors quand on empêche la justice faire
son travail
cette année où c'est un monde et
n'exerce pas nombreux chez moi cette
semaine avec donnedieu de vabres la
justice arrive quand même à travailler
sur cet avis la justice arrive à
travailler mais avec peine et
aujourd'hui on freine son travail et
jeudi le pouvoir
aujourd'hui le travail de ceux qui
enquêtent sur la faire sonner quand même
en sortant de là que la ficelle est un
peu grosse
on ressort l affaire karachi pour
pourquoi faire passer un petit peu le la
sphère du pas de calais qui a occupé le
début de la semaine la sphère du pas de
calais c'est une affaire qui touche
semble-t-il un élu nous
disons libération je la fédération la
fédération du pas de calais a eu de ses
comptes qui chaque année ont été
validées par un expert-comptable validé
et sur lequel nie absolument rien à
redire tout cas le coach sait s'il est
un beau monde et s'il y a aujourd'hui
des choses qui te sont reprochés à
quelqu'un que la justice fasse son
travail nous n'avons pas de position
avait nommé une commission d'enquêté je
remarque semble clairement entendu
puisque quand ça touche le parti
socialiste nous souhaitons aussi pouvoir
faire la clarté sur ce que l'on dit et
donc sans attendre nous diligentons des
moyens dans 99 à chaque fois quand même
qu'il ya un an de montebourg qui monte
un peu au créneau pour qu'on fasse le
ménage dans les canaries cool arnaud
montebourg n'est pas en cause sur les
crèmes voulons non attendez je voulais
simplement cliquer sur je voulais
simplement vous dire que vouloir dans
l'hémicycle mettre en avant l' affaire
qui pourrait concerner un élu et sur
lequel nous demandons à ce que la
justice fasse son travail avec une
affaire de plusieurs millions d'euros de
francs qui a entraîné la mort de
plusieurs français
je crois qu'on n'est pas responsables
quand l'on fait comme le gouvernement de
tel parallèle et donc de ce point de vue
là ce que je dis ici c'est que l'
affaire karachi doit être une affaire où
tout soit enfin mis sur la table où la
justice puisse faire son travail que
cela touche ou pas le président de la
république nicolas sarkozy pour le pas
de calais mais bien entendu mais bien
entendu
moi je vais vous poser une question sur
le monde où je continue donc ma question
il écrit une lettre qui doit rester à
peu près normalement autre légende du
parti socialiste et puis se trouve et
bien que cette lettre parue dans la
presse on dit que ça serait par
l'intermédiaire de martine aubry ça sent
le règlement de comptes le troisième
tour des primaires n'auront coutelas pas
l'impression de deux enfants que ça qui
est un vrai règlement contre parti
socialiste là je vais jouer le porte
parole de françois hollande françois
hollande aujourd'hui il n'est pas dans
ces affaires là s'il y avait eu des
civils mais s'il y avait des règles les
uns et les autres même temps ce que je
dis c'est que quand on s'adresse des
lettres en politique on a toujours le
risque que ces lettres soit rendu public
et donc il faut toujours mesurer les
expressions pendant connais bien jean
pierre cochet by pouvait on pouvait
ignorer à ce point il ignore à ce point
les affaires du parti qu'il pouvait se
dire qu'il y avait peut-être des choses
un peu douteuse dans la fédération
écouter s'il y a des choses douteuses
que la justice fasse son travail pour
l'heure
nous avons aujourd'hui plusieurs
centaines d'élus que françois hollande a
rencontré durant toute sa vie il les a
rencontrés comme militant socialiste il
a toujours été fière des victoires ils
ont apporté au parti socialiste on a
découvert avec cette lettre qu'il
pouvait y avoir quelques malversations
possible mais en tout cas ils n'en
avaient pas eu connaissance
et s'il s'agit d'affaires personnelles
puisqu'il ne s'agit pas d' affaires
politiques qu'il n'y a pas de questions
de financement de parti politique qui
soit en jeu avec cela s'il doit y avoir
des enquêtes mais qu'elle commence sans
tarder et qu'elle est très varié très
vite qu elle sans s'arrêter
mais bien entendu que la justice fasse
son travail va s'intéresser à nouveau au
travail de l'assemblée nationale c'est
un rapport qui gênent 700 pages du
financement des syndicats six mois de
travail
une centaine de personnes auditionnées
le rapport a été rejetée par la
commission d' enquête parlementaire est
plus rare il n'a pas été rendu publics
les explications de florence maurice six
mois de travail 45 auditions et 29
propositions au pilon c'était le 30
novembre dernier le rapport
parlementaire sur le financement des
organisations syndicales et patronales
est rejetée à la dernière minute
le groupe ump a décidé de s'abstenir le
député rapporteur de ce texte ne cache
pas alors son amertume c'est une
position de principe évidemment de l'ump
sur ce sujet là qui ne souhaite pas
qu'on ouvre encore une fois le dossier
de l'argent des syndicats sont le
respect du travail parlementaire c'est
quand même pas terrible parce qu'un
président de groupe qui qui appelle les
commissaires enquêteurs un par un pour
leur demander de s'abstenir
je trouve que c'est pas très joli de
l'aveu même du député ce document ne
contiendrait pourtant rien d'explosif
mais tout de même quelques chiffres
étonnants seuls 3 % des ressources
syndicale proviendrait des cotisations
d'adhérents
en clair les syndicats dépendrait très
largement de l'argent public et les
contrôles seraient inexistants
ce matin la cgt et la cfdt dément ce
chiffre et regrette que les informations
qui circulent met surtout en cause les
syndicats de salariés
je n'avais pas le droit sous peine
d'amendé de pouvoir le commenter donc je
demande la publication de ce rapport
parce que je le dis très clair encore
une fois ce matin c'est pas l'argent des
syndicats qui a mis en cause c'est
l'argent du financement au parti qui les
organisations patronales jeu
adressée au président de l'assemblée
nationale monsieur acoyer et je vais lui
demander officiellement au nom de la cgt
la publication de ce rapport de la
commission d' enquête sur les
financements
dans son document nicolas perruchot
donne également des pistes pour
renforcer la transparence et les
contrôles mais le rapport est
actuellement enfermé dans les archives
de l'assemblée nationale sauf nouveau
rebondissement
il ne sera pas possible de le consulter
avant 2041 la rue non le roux les
mangues la commission parlementaire
n'ont pas voté du parti socialiste n'ont
pas voté ce texte pourquoi situation est
ubuesque nous n'étions pas en accord
avec les conclusions du rapport qui nous
semblaient être des conclusions qui
concerne est beaucoup trop les
organisations syndicales et pas du tout
les organisations patronales portant
nicolas perruchot l'auteur du rapport
dit que c'est égal salaire est
appareillée nous avons jugé que ça ne
l'était pas et donc nous n'approuvons
pas les mesures qu'il propose est et
pour autant il ya eu un travail de fait
et nous souhaitons bien entendu que ce
travail soit rendue publique
ce n'est pas parce que l'on approuve pas
les propositions d'un rapport que ce
rapport n'existe pas et il doit exister
il doit être connu et donc le président
de l'assemblée nationale ne peut pas
user d'arguties pour rejoindre ce n'est
pas le rendre public entière comment
c'est la loi il dit que c'est la loi ne
peut pas sortir le rapport c'est la loi
publié les députés ump qui avait assuré
aux rapporteurs qu'il le soutiendrait ne
l'ont pas fait n'ont pas eu le courage
de le soutenir
et ils ont donc rendu impossible par
leur abstention
l'adoption de ce rapport c'est très rare
qu'un rapport soit fait par quelqu'un
qui appartient à la majorité et qu'il
soit pas votée là c'est le cas donc ce
n'est pas l'opposition l'opposition elle
a trouvé qu'il n'était pas utile aux
rapports ou du simplement au fait qu'on
s'attaque aux syndicats je crois que
c'est dû aux rapports enfin je ne sais
pas pourquoi les députés ump ne l'ont
pas approuvé ce rapport mais ce que nous
disons nous ce que nous savons nous
pourquoi c'est parce qu'il nous semblait
déséquilibrée et nous souhaitons que ce
déséquilibre n'entraîne pas
l'idée qu'ils soient fausses et donc
pour qu'il n'y ait pas des défauts s'il
ya eu un travail de fait par un
parlementaire
nous demandons à ce que ce travail soit
rendue publique vous avez une deuxième
chance une session de rattrapage
puisqu'il va y avoir le 26 janvier si je
ne m'abuse une proposition de loi
centriste qui va être examinée et qui
propose notamment plus de transparence
pour le financement des comités
d'entreprise est-ce que vous social et
vous serez au côté des centristes pour
doter sa corne existeront en groupe de
la position je ne connais pas encore la
proposition de loi j'ai bien vu qu'il
voulait reprendre deux des propositions
moi je dis que quand on reprend deux des
propositions il est bien de les
connaître tout est donc je demande au
groupe centriste de dire qu'elles
étaient toutes les propositions et
pourquoi ils n'en n'ont retenu que deux
pourquoi pas les autres pour éclairer le
débat et nous éclaire heureux encore
mieux le débat si le président de
l'assemblée nationale cédait à ce geste
renoncer à ce geste partisans qui est de
bloquer un rapport qui ne plaît pas aux
députés ump
ouais d'accord pour dire que s'attaquer
aux syndicats à quelques mois des
élections présidentielles c'est
peut-être un peu dangereux c'est pour ça
qu'on nous met un peu sous le tapis le
rapport mais là c'est encore pire
on s'attaque aux syndicats et on ne dit
pas en quoi on s'attaquait à eux les
syndicats savent que ce rapport existe
et donc ils vont auditionner ça risque
d'être musclé l'assemblée nationale ils
les syndicats je vous permets de le
rappeler demande la publication de ce
rapport
aujourd'hui et je trouve qu'il n'est pas
normal que ce soit dans le débat public
aujourd'hui un certain nombre d'idées un
certain nombre de choses dont on ne sait
pas ce qu elles sont vraies ou fausses
parce qu'on n'a pas le rapport est donc
je demande la publication de ce rapport
à l'art au passo jeudi jacques chirac
condamné
le tribunal correctionnel de paris en ce
jeudi n'aura donc pas tenu compte des
réquisitions du procureur pas de relaxe
pour jacques chirac mais deux ans de
prison avec sursis dans la sphère des
emplois fictifs de la mairie de paris
l'ancien maire de la capitale a été
déclaré coupable de détournement de
fonds publics abus de confiance prise
illégale d'intérêts il n'a pas fait
appel le jugement est donc définitif
cette condamnation d'un ex-président est
une première historique qui bien sûr a
suscité beaucoup de réactions c'est un
sujet de florence maurice une réaction à
la condamnation de monsieur chirac aux
questions d'actualité d'un merci que
pensez-vous de la condamnation de
monsieur chirac rien à droite la
condamnation de jacques chirac laisse la
classe politique perplexe d'un côté la
justice de l'autre un homme
le premier ministre regrette une
condamnation vingt ans après les faits
je pense simplement que celle ci arrive
vraiment trop tard plus de vingt ans
après les faits c'est une décision qui à
mon sens ne viendra pas altéré la
relation personnelle qui existe entre
les français et jacques chirac à gauche
pas question non plus d'accabler l'ex
président
surtout pas françois hollande son ancien
adversaire de corrèze
j'ai une pensée pour l'homme jacques
chirac qui est connaît en plus des
ennuis de santé
la condamnation est sévère elle est à la
fois pénale et moral et elle touche tom
donc j'ai une pensée pour lui même si la
justice devait passer pour eva joly
ce jugement doit conduire jacques chirac
a démissionné du conseil constitutionnel
parce que je le compare avec le
recrutement des magistrats
il faut avoir un casier judiciaire
vierge
donc c'est une exigence pour moi
démocratique
que jacques chirac se retire démissionne
un jugement qui intervient après une
procédure longue et semée d'embûches
l'occasion à gauche de réclamer une
nouvelle fois une révision du statut
pénal du chef de l'état
là est ce qu on un jour bruno le roux on
a encore désacralisé la fonction
présidentielle
non justement je pense qu'on a montré
qu'il ne pouvait pas y avoir d'impunité
la justice a montré cela et en même
temps on voit bien que les délais ne
sont pas des délais raisonnables quand
on juge vingt ans plus tard et donc fait
mal oui bien entendu
mais françois fillon devrait en tirer la
même conclusion que nous c'est à dire
qu'il faut pour cela pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de délai aussi long
il faut faire évoluer le statut pénal du
chef de l'état
il faut non pas désacralisé la fonction
mais faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait plus
ce sentiment d'impunité qui ne finissent
que 20 ans plus tard et donc quand il ya
des faits qui ont été commis avant
l'entrée en fonction pendant il doit y
avoir une commission constituée chargé
de regarder s'il doit y avoir la justice
qui passe dès maintenant sans attendre
ou alors si l'on est dans une plainte
qui est une plainte sans objet dans une
désacralisation de la fonction fait des
années qu'on conjugent un président en
exercice
oui c'est compatible avec la fonction de
chef de l'état mais ça dépend et donc il
doit y avoir une commission qui soit
chargée d'examiner ça parce que cela
dépend des faits qui sont commis ce qui
est le plus grave c'est la voir un
président de la république qui soit
suspects qu'ils soient suspects pendant
son mandat et qui ne répondent pas
aujourd'hui aux sollicitations qui
permettent de lever ces suspicions de ce
point de vue là monsieur sarkozy devrait
autoriser le rendu public de tous les
documents de la sphère karachi car
aujourd'hui il est dans une situation
difficile cette levée notamment
est ce que vous proposez de changement
du statut pénal du chef de l'état ça
sera dans le programme de françois
hollande
bien entendu ce sera un des éléments
d'évolution démocratique de nos
institutions clés il n'est pas question
de pouvoir revivre demain avec un autre
président ce qui a été vécu là avec un
tel délai pour les français quelque
chose qu'il s'apparente bien entendu à
une décision de justice
il n'y a pas eu d' impunité mais en même
temps qu'il n'a plus quand la décision
est si éloignée des faits elle ne peut
plus elle est à l'adresse d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui à l'homme alors qu'à
l'époque ce qui devait être condamné
c'est un système
eva joly par exemple qui demande à ce
qu'il quitte le conseil constitutionnel
alors qu'ils les deux faits de droit
donc s'est constitué un conseil
constitutionnel coûté moi je nos
institutions notre constitution est très
claire là dessus et je veux dire que
c'est un système pour moi qui a été
condamné un système qui avaient été
mises en place avant qu'il n'y ait de
véritables règles de financement de
notre vie politique et je veux dire
aujourd'hui dans la situation où il a le
respect en même temps la pensée il j'ai
pour l'ancien président la république
on va finir bruno le roux cette émission
avec une question d'actualité
le premier ministre turc rask
erdogan demande à nicolas sarkozy de
retirer un texte un texte sur le
génocide arménien à un débat qui aura
lieu la semaine prochaine à l'assemblée
nationale avec un texte sur la sanction
du déni de négationnisme
est-ce que vous pensez que monsieur
erdogan a tort de s'immiscer dans la vie
française oui je pense qu'il a tort je
pense qu'il a tort pour notre débat
d'ailleurs nous n'avons pas à entendre
nous avons entendre mais nous ne
réagissons pas en fonction des volontés
de monsieur dégâts mais je crois qu'il a
tort aussi pour l'avancée dans toute
cette région il y a besoin pour
affronter ce 21ème siècle de solder
cette question du génocide arménien et
aujourd'hui je demande aux arméniens et
aux turcs de le faire et il ne peut se
faire que par la reconnaissance cela a
été fait par la france du génocide
arménien et en même temps empêcher qu'il
y ait toute négation de ce génocide et
dont je crois que ce que nous faisons
c'est un acte de réconciliation est pas
un acte de division monsieur erdogan qui
menace de conséquences graves y compris
économique on me répond quoi mais que là
dedans
la france est un pays qui est un pays
souverain qu'elle fait la loi comme elle
longtemps et qu'elle fait cette loi non
pas pour son propre confort mais pour
faire en sorte que la volonté progresse
de des changes qui soit équilibrée qui
soit sur une base historique
indiscutable ce que nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il puisse y avoir
de nouvelle page ouverte attendent les
relais entre l'europe entre l'europe et
la turquie et pour avoir de nouvelles
pages ouvertes entre l'europe et la
turquie
il y a une chose qui est centrale c'est
cette reconnaissance est histoire
assumer
c'est de reconnaissance du génocide
arménien au fait de ne pas pouvoir le
lier ces textes et la semaine prochaine
à l'assemblée on le rappelle qui
sanctionnerait le déni de génocide vous
le vôtre et entendu je le voterai et
bien cette émission est terminé merci
d'avoir été avec nous bonne fête et nous
nous retrouvons nous allons marcher
oui sûrement ça devrait certainement
faire tout le monde monsanto vous mangez
bien on se retrouve en 2012 orban est à
tout le monde à revoir